also breaking this evening police are  investigating a homicide in the central  valley this happened on vegas valley  drive near maryland parkway around 1 30  this afternoon police say two men got  into an argument in an apartment over an  apparent stolen cell phone that's when  one man or one of the men rather pulled  out a gun and started shooting the other  man believed to be between the ages of  25 and 30 fired back hitting the older  man he was taken to sunrise where he  died the suspect is still on the run  tonight so if you know anything police  are encouraging you to reach out to  crime stoppers there is a reward for any  information